um diese strecke vor
[Musik]
willkommen beim ein video
ja ich weiß mein shirt ist extrem eng
und das regt mich gab auch ein bisschen
aus wie arbeite ich hoffe euch jetzt gut
auf jeden fall
29 ich habe lange überlegt ob ich noch
mal was zu dem thema machen kann
beziehungsweise machen sollte aber es
ist folgendes passiert dann muss man
auch mal sagen schaut an meinen neuen
mitbewohner immer was ist auf jeden fall
haben wir letztens auf seinem schimmel
eine webpage gedreht das heißt ganz
einfach das prinzip mit zu erklären
das hätte ich mir nicht zugetraut dass
du so was erklären kannst arbeit werde
auf jeden fall jeder 4 kommentare
ausgesucht von dem video von bab 5 sie
haben wie gesagt ich müsste mir auch
fünf eingeholt das heißt ich prüfe die
auf darunter dem video stehen nämlich
glaube ich fast eine million kommentare
und wir haben uns gedacht wir suchen
welche raus die sind aber nicht alle
riehl so der juni hat jetzt vier
ausgesucht davon sind halt irgendwelche
real also ich bin wirklich runter und
irgendwelche hat er sich nur ausgedacht
und wir werden die uns jetzt gegenseitig
vor und der andere aus dem niemand
erwarten steht dass da wirklich drunter
oder etwas nur kompletter schwachsinn
der fun irakkrieg nacken fälle
nebensachen von gürtel so können auch
maschinen schlag also gewichtigen so
richtig so genau ich warne euch das
video wo ich gegen den newcomer
angetreten bin einfach mal in der video
beschreibung und wir fangen jetzt an
flagge anfängt schnick schnack schnuck
schnellster
ich finde das nicht toll ich liebe dich
dein leon ich liebe dich ich liebe das
liegt sind ich will dein leben fragt sie
saison beziehungsweise der songtext
ergeben meiner meinung nach einfach
keinen sinn für den teenager kommentar
der heute habe ich locker zehn minuten
drin gewesen
ich bin jetzt erst aus meinem kopf
angekommen ich bin jetzt erst aus meinem
koma erwacht also ich kann mich nicht
mehr an einen einzelnen tag erinnern
seit dem 5 52
beliebt sind dank an die erst wird die
alle meine innereien die ich erbrochen
habe wieder in die hinein bekommen haben
und mein leblosen körper der kaufinger
hat anlaufen lassen haben aber ich bin
jetzt total ein werk das direkt rolle
wie zwei millionen entweder du hast da
gerade recht gleiche kranken oder kleben
oder früher erzählt ich würde sagen
gefühl ist riesig
ich denke was hat er gebraucht um etwas
zu kommen zeug hat jetzt obliegt da
unten daten bekommt ihr geld gehört hat
eine packung schmerzmittel so an sich
wie schon gesagt das sind so viele
kommentare unter und das muss auf jeden
fall - zweimal darunter sind viel
weniger rechts
ja aber ich wette das hat zählt wer
darunter geschrieben so nach dem
videowürfel packung aspirin geschenkt
bekommen ok 11 es okay baby hat jan
kommentar hin geschrieben
thank you so much for your support
unbelievable daraufhin hat jemand
vielleicht beantwortet wer weiß wie miss
you die pelle
mein gott ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
du so schön singen kannst und der
kommentar soll wohl vielleicht 22.000
gleichsam ist der mehrerer vor 22.000
gleich dafür dass die vielen gewinnen
ich sag dir trier ich habe davon auch
gesehen dass der 64.000 allgemeine
kommentare wenn ihr da oben war
leute ich war übrigens weitere burgert
kann man das zu akzeptieren so oder ist
das zweite treffen kommentar wenig es
dass man rock singt oder auch der welt
gibt es jetzt seht ihr nicht immer noch
1 1
jetzt haben wir noch den letzten und er
entscheidet jetzt kannst du dich in die
kirche gehen und julian einfach das
essen machen
meinst du ich glaube das heißt würde
sagen ich habe 4 kommentare ausgeübt
januar waren im mittelalter hätte das
hier als folter gegeben hätte gut drei
millionen darunter im mittelalter das
folter gestand dass dann irgendwann
größer
dies gilt als folge haben sich drauf
gemacht mit mittelalter leute selber
nicht so sein wo wir hätten viel früher
ist scheißegal leid mega
[Musik]
bis zum gipfel einheit
für angst ich hab was etwa 30 leute
erklärt dazu ich hoffe immer kleiner
ich hoffe das video hat euch gefallen
mir hat es super gefallen hat auf jeden
fall spaß macht auch wenn es leicht weh
tut immer noch weh
[Musik]
und bitte auch kein vorbei ist ich
verdanke sie doch in der beschreibung
passt auch mal ein leichter und was
beweist dass man ist ja gerade ein
rennen
[Musik]